First we want to check to see if there's a greatest common factor other than 1,
1 is the greatest common factor for all three terms, so we don't need to factor
anything out. We want to find factors of negative 120 that sum to positive 14.
Here's the start of a factor pair list. There are other factors for negative 120
but I already found the one I need, negative 6 and positive 20. We can check
this real quick to make sure negative 6 times 20 multiplies to negative 120, and
that they sum to positive 14. It's best to rewrite 14a with a negative term
first. We finish out our problem by factoring by grouping, and these are two
factors, 3a plus 4 and 5a minus 2. That's some great work if you got that one
correct. If these are giving you trouble, stay with it. The more practice you
do, the better you'll get at math. As you put in more effort, you will improve.